a dream come true we're gonna try to
give the best Super Bowl show every boy
did they deliver Jennifer Lopez and
Shakira brought the house down during
the Super Bowl 54 halftime show the
Latin divas performed at their greatest
hits
[Music]
JLo had a screaming when she brought her
hustlers moves to the stage wearing a
nearly their silver jumpsuit jennifer is
going to perform for herself for a
family but for all the women out there
who are mothers who are so responsible
and she's gonna show what a mother with
children a working mom can do today in
front of 150 million people including
her fiancé Alex Rodriguez who delivers
the ultimate fangirl moment in the
audience
[Applause]
[Music]
Shakira gave us an epic guitar solo play
the drums and reminded us all about her
hip still don't like your show and my
show feel very different but very
complimentary they complement each other
and I think that we've been working so
hard the past weeks to make sure that
everything is as good as good as we can
feel it that it is and so everybody can
enjoy this Sunday enjoy a great show the
price cash tape alvin and fat bunny
brought reggaeton to the main stage and
it doesn't stop there
Jennifer's 11 year old daughter proof
she's following in Mama's foots death
Petey was backstage with a-rod's
daughters who couldn't be more happy for
her the coolest thing to watch my
stepsister saying I'm so proud of her
every time I see her and her voice is
just angelic Emma's dad Marc Anthony was
also proud tweeting Emmy daddy is so
proud of you you are my heart and I am
forever yours other celebs showed the
Superbowl ladies some love Lady gaga
tweeted what a fun halftime show I
danced and smiled the whole time such
powerful sexy women Khloe Kardashian was
all of us saying their energy gave me
energy
fangirling for sure but the funniest
tweet goes to Joe Jonas he tweeted out
this moment that has everyone talking
yeah that shakira ferociously wagging
her tongue at the camera in a
three-second shot we can never unsee
it's safe to say this was arguably the
best Superbowl halftime performance ever
now you celebrate
[Music]